In the high middle ages, new farming
methods started boosting efficiency.
Tools like the heavy plow helped turn
the soil better, allowing fewer people
to feed more. So from 90% farmers, the
number dropped to 80%. And suddenly 10%
of the population was free to do other
work. that freed up labor made it
possible for cities to grow, for grand
churches to rise, and for a clerical
class to form. Without a solid food base
like the grain supplies that once made
Egypt the bread basket of the Roman
Empire, there would have been no way to
support armies or complex governments.
The figure of 90% highlights just how
important the farming class was in the
Middle Ages. They fed the entire social
system and kept the wheels of progress
turning. But the farmers weren't all the
same. Among them were tenant farmers who
worked their own plots, surfs who were
mostly unfree and worked on a lord's
estate, day laborers without land of
their own, and cottages who had only a
small house and perhaps a garden but no
fields.
In the high middle ages, the idea of a
three-part society took shape. Those who
pray, the clergy, those who fight, the
nobles and knights, and those who work,
the farmers. Over time, this system
became more fixed. Though in the early
Middle Ages, it had been less clearly
defined.
The first written records of this social
division come from the early 11th
century.
They described three social groups and
placed farmers at the bottom since their
work fed and supported the rest of
society.
Roman traditions played a key role in
shaping the status of farmers. In the
Roman system, large estates in places
like Egypt or Italy ran mainly on slave
labor. But as Europe moved from late
antiquity into the early medieval
period, the big waves of migration
stopped. Germanic tribes settled down,
taking up farming and hering. With this
settled life came a bond to the land. A
farmer could no longer leave his plot
without violating his duties to the
landowner.
The farmer's role as a warrior began to
fade. Only in rare cases were free
farmers still called up as soldiers.
Interestingly, there were no permanent
villages in the early Middle Ages, at
least not as we know them today. People
often lived on designated estate farms
or in very small temporary settlements.
After about 40 years, these settlements
were usually abandoned because the
intensely worked soil became exhausted.
Although the three field system where
onethird of the land layow each year was
known as early as the 9th century, it
wasn't widely practiced for a long time
largely due to limited access to
fertilizer. When a field became worn
out, it was simply used as pasture. And
when even that no longer worked, the
settlement had to move. So the kind of
permanent village we are familiar with
today barely existed back then. One
remarkable constant however was the
burial ground. Cemeteries always lay
outside the living area but over time
they often became surrounded by new
houses.
Another reason why permanent villages
emerged only later was technological
limitation.
In the early Middle Ages, the most
common plow was the light scratch plow,
which only worked the soil surface and
was poorly suited to the wet, low-lying
soils found in regions like the
Rhineland or along the Ela. Adding to
the challenge, draft animals often
didn't wear horseshoes, making them
ineffective on soft or marshy ground. It
wasn't until the high middle ages that
people began draining many bogs and
wetlands through ditches and channels,
making them fit for farming. Gradually,
they reclaimed new land by draining
wetlands, cutting down forests, and
turning wild spaces into farmland.
Often, these were areas without any
Roman past. No old roads, no aqueducts,
no towns. Step by step, a new farming
world took shape.
In the early Middle Ages, land ownership
was split mainly between kings, counts,
who acted as representatives of the
ruling powers over a fragmented
landscape, and monasteries, which also
served as landlords.
A traveling king had no unified
territory. His royal estates were
scattered across the realm. He would
move from one estate to another with his
court and officials, collecting tithes
and military service along the way. At
this stage, the noble line wasn't firmly
established yet, and property often came
through inheritance or marriage
connections. The core of the economic
system back then was the so-called
Salhof, Terra Salica.
This referred to the lord's personal
land worked directly by unfree peasants.
Servy alongside these lands there were
semif-free farms where peasant families
sometimes under the supervision of an
appointed overseer worked their own
plots. They paid dues often in the form
of goods like grain, livestock or wine
and sometimes through services like
military duties.
This system was seen as an improvement
over the ancient Roman slave model
because these peasants, whether semifree
or unfree, had at least some level of
self-sufficiency.
The lord didn't need centralized slave
barracks. Instead, he benefited from
regular dues while investing as little
effort as possible in feeding his
workforce.
Once the lord had supplies, whether meat
from a butcher, bread from a bakery, or
wine from his seller, he could
redistribute them across his network of
estates. This created domini or holdings
that ran on minimal fixed costs.
At the center of it all was the hoof,
the basic unit of farmland. It wasn't a
fixed size. It was just about how much
land two oxmen could plow in a day.
But this amount changed a lot depending
on the local soil and customs. In the
north, a hoof was usually smaller than
in the south. You can think of a hoof
kind of like the old Morgan, meaning the
land a team of oxen could plow in a
morning, but there was no exact
standard.
Over time, more and more resources were
attached to the Salhof. Mills, ins, bake
houses, and wine presses increasingly
came under direct noble control.
This arrangement lasted well into the
late Middle Ages because as some
lordships grew larger, entire local
economies became effectively
nationalized.
Legal authority also gradually shifted
to the landlords. In the early Middle
Ages, there were still counts appointed
specifically for judicial matters, but
little by little, landlords absorbed
these powers. This deepened the farmer's
dependency. Anyone seeking protection
from a powerful ruler had to become a
subject. For some unfree peasants,
however, this was actually an
opportunity. Under the protection of a
mighty noble or a wealthy monastery,
they could sometimes secure a better
position than if they were left exposed
in lawless, dangerous regions.
Chapter 2. Agricultural Revolution and
Social Differentiation in the High
Middle Ages.
In the High Middle Ages, Europe saw what
can only be called a population boom.
New farming methods, technical progress,
and the rise of organized village
communities meant that the nobility
gradually stepped back from owning
individual farms. Instead of managing
the land themselves, they handed it over
as mer or ding farms to largecale
farmers who worked the fields on their
behalf. The rest of the peasants were
mostly seen as independent
entrepreneurs, but they still owed taxes
and labor services, especially so-called
frondinster.
These included manual labor and span
services where a peasant had to provide
his horses or oxen for mandatory
transport duties.
In many regions, such obligations
continued all the way into the early
17th century. At the same time, villages
became more permanent with cooperative
self-governance emerging. In many
places, peasants jointly manage the use
of fields, farming schedules, and the
taxes owed to their lord. Froinster or
labor obligations often meant that a
peasant with his own team of horses or
oxen had to help haul goods for the
lord. Meanwhile, a peasant without a
team owning only a small plot might be
required to give more manual labor
because he couldn't pay in kind.
Alongside these social shifts, the three
field system spread widely.
Onethird of a village's land was sewn
with summer grain like oats or barley.
Another third with winter grain like
wheat or rye and the final third was
left or used as pasture so the soil
could recover. This crop rotation led to
a huge increase in yields. Compared to
the early middle ages, farmers now often
harvested double or even triple the
previous amount per acre. Fertilization
became more effective, too. Stable
manure and ashes from slash and burn
clearing briefly enriched soils. But the
real driver behind this agricultural
revolution was technological progress.
The heavy plow known from ancient
sources spread through central Europe
starting in the 10th century. Its unique
feature was the mold board which didn't
just break the ground but fully turned
it over. This made it possible to farm
heavy wet lowland soils. Places like the
elber lowlands or the rin area. Horses
became the main draft animals supported
by a new type of harness, the horse
collar, which let them pull much more
efficiently. A single horse could now
pull the same as a pair of oxmen, but
faster and with greater endurance.
Iron tools also emerged, including
sidesthes, sickles, spades, and harrows,
stronger and more efficient than the old
wooden tools. With all these advances,
agricultural yields soared and Europe's
population roughly tripled between the
11th and 13th centuries. This led to
massive settlement movements. Some
villages expanded by dividing into upper
and lower parts while others
participated in the eastward migration
beyond the Elba. In these eastern areas,
once covered in Slavic forests, settlers
cleared the land. sometimes clashing
with local Slavic communities before
permanent colonization took hold.
During this period, countless new towns
sprang up. Between the 11th and 15th
centuries, medieval Europe transformed
dramatically. Long-d distanceance trade,
coinbased economies, and the rise of
marketplaces increasingly connected
rural regions to urban centers.
Farmers brought their surplus goods to
town markets where they could in turn
buy metal tools, ceramics, and other
items. The saying city air makes you
free emerged, meaning that anyone who
entered a town and lived there for a
year and a day could free themselves
from feudal obligations.
Similarly, clearing land makes you free
was common. Anyone who cleared and
farmed unused land could often claim
rights similar to those of free farmers.
Around the year 1300, Europe's landscape
was more densely populated than today.
There were more villages, although each
was typically smaller in size. Fields,
meadows, and riverlands were marked off
by walls, hedges, or fences. Forests
were no longer wild, untouched places,
but carefully managed woodlands. Pigs,
sheep, and cattle grazed there, and some
forest areas were used as communal
grazing grounds, like orchard pastures
or hut forests, where animals could
roam. Despite the huge gains in crop
yields during the high middle ages,
sometimes three to four times the output
of earlier centuries, serious problems
arose from soil exhaustion, manure
shortages, and erosion.
The Great Magdalene flood of 1342 was a
devastating disaster that reshaped much
of Europe's river systems. Torrential
rains raised river levels dramatically,
washing away soil, breaking dikes and
destroying farmland.
Major rivers like the Rine, Danube, and
Ela, as well as smaller waterways across
central and eastern Europe, saw villages
heavily damaged or completely swept
away.
At the time, some prime agricultural
lands still delivered two or three times
the seed sown. But many marginal plots,
areas that had been newly brought under
cultivation,
collapsed. They eroded so badly that
they had to be abandoned.
Livestock farming, once a vital pillar
of the rural economy, faded into the
background as crossd district grain
farming proved more profitable.
In many regions, even poor soils were
converted to farmland, but these lands
yielded little grain in return. As a
result, the overall crop yield per acre
stagnated or even declined.
As farming systems became more strained,
medieval Europe grew more vulnerable to
crop failures.
Already in the 14th century, famines
broke out sporadically, sometimes
limited to one region, sometimes
affecting wide areas. For example, in
the year 1345,
vast stretches of land from northern
Spain to northern Italy suffered from
severe food shortages.
Then came the Black Death. Between 1343
and 1346, the plague swept through
central Europe, wiping out up to a third
of the population.
As a result, grain prices dropped
sharply. Suddenly, supply far exceeded
the reduced demand. Fields were
abandoned, often starting with the least
productive plots. This process of rewing
farmland actually boosted yields on the
remaining land as more labor could now
be concentrated on fewer acres.
Peasants who had barely scraped by
before now found themselves in a
stronger bargaining position. With less
available land and fewer workers, they
became highly sought after. At first,
this shift brought clear advantages for
the peasantry. But as the famine and
plague years faded, new challenges
emerged. Population growth slowed or
barely recovered as many crops and
livestock had been wiped out. Yet taxes
and labor dues were still being
collected and in some cases landlords
began converting these to cash payments,
preferring money over grain which they
couldn't easily store. By around 1450, a
clear trend was emerging. Feudal labor
services, compulsory duties, and surfom
itself were gradually retreating across
many regions. Peasants gained new
privileges. They formed cooperatives to
collectively govern their villages and
began adding small trades or crafts to
their local economies. things like
blacksmithing, weaving or milling which
offered extra income sources. In some
places, these changes effectively ended
surfom. At the same time, agriculture
diversified
alongside high yield crop farming.
Livestock production, especially cattle
for milk, butter, and cheese regained
importance. Vegetable and garden farming
also became more prominent with crops
like cabbage, turnips, and legumes. In
some areas, the shift was so advanced
that the share of livestock and dairy in
the rural economy gradually rivaled that
of crop farming.
Chapter 3. Daily life and family
structures of medieval peasants.
Let's set aside the old stereotype that
peasant homes were little more than dirt
floor huts. In reality, during the high
and late middle ages, peasant buildings
came in many forms, showing impressive
regional diversity and craftsmanship.
Early on, postframe houses were common.
These were built by driving thick wooden
posts directly into the ground with
beams laid across the top, but they
didn't last long. The upright posts
rotted quickly in damp soil. By the 11th
century, in forested regions, people
began using frame construction similar
to half-timbering. Vertical posts were
placed on stone or brick foundations
carrying the weight of the roof while
the spaces between them were filled with
wle and dob or wooden planks. On many
manor lands or in peasant villages you
could find a mix of these building
styles. For example, a farmhouse might
have an old postframe section attached
to a newer blockbuilt parlor. In the
alpine foothills, such combinations were
fairly common.
By the late middle ages, the famous
lowger German hall house or hall and
barn house had emerged. A structure
where both the living quarters and the
animal stalls were housed under a single
roof. Contrary to popular belief, late
medieval peasants had wooden beam
ceilings, plastered walls, and even
window inserts. Some wealthier farming
families added wooden wall paneling made
from steamed pine or oak and they built
ceramic stoves to keep their rooms warm
in winter. In places like South Tier
near Clausen, medieval parlors still
survive today, showing whitewashed walls
and beautifully crafted wood paneling.
Peasant interiors ranged widely from
smoky dark spaces with little furniture
to cozy rooms with carved benches,
curtains, and candle chandeliers for
extra comfort.
Family life was usually patriarchal and
patrioal, meaning the father ruled as
the head of the household, the house v,
while the mother, often living with the
husband's family, managed the home, the
stable, and the kitchen. Until the
agricultural crisis, it was nearly
impossible to leave the farm without a
lord's permission or protection, meaning
families stayed rooted in one place.
daughters typically married into nearby
villages, often to farms under church or
noble patronage. A typical household
included the heirs, often just one son,
or in cases of shared inheritance, all
sons, along with the mother, father, and
grandparents if they were still alive.
Depending on the farm's size, there
might also be hired hands, male and
female servants, and even landless
relatives who had no inheritance rights.
Farm owners known as stam farmers often
maintained a small household staff who
worked unpaid within the family economy,
receiving only food and lodging in
exchange. This labor setup set medieval
peasants apart from modern wage
laborers. Cash payments like small
annual rents were rare. Instead, the
system functioned largely on direct
subsistence and barter. The medieval
farmer held extensive rights, often
summed up under the term house and farm
rights. Within his household, he could
impose punishments on family members or
servants, control who came and went, and
handled disputes that arose under his
roof. Passing the farm to the next
generation followed two main legal
traditions. Real division, common under
Frankish law, or indivisible inheritance
under Saxon law. Real division meant
that when there were several sons, the
farm was split into equal parts. As a
result, each heir worked a smaller
portion of land, and depending on the
farm's size, they often had to find
secondary sources of income. In
contrast, under old Saxon law, the
indivisible inheritance system was used.
Here only one son, usually the eldest,
inherited the entire farm, while the
brothers received smaller plots, partial
shares or cash payments. This kept large
farms intact, boosting both economic
efficiency and social stability.
Below the full farmers, those owning
entire farmsteads, were many social
tiers. There were quarter, half or
eighth farmers who only controlled part
of a full farm. Then came the cottages
who had no farmland, just a small house
with a garden, and often rented fields
or worked as drivers and haulers.
Day laborers typically owned neither
land nor garden, and worked by the day
for wages and meals, either on farms or
for lords. Servants, both male and
female, were entirely landless and lived
on others farms without any claim to
farm status. Within the village, only
full farmers and sometimes half farmers
had political rights. They could be
elected to local offices such as village
judge or juror. All other groups were
effectively excluded from local
governance and had to rely on their lord
to represent their interests. Social
standing wasn't just defined by land
ownership, but also by livestock.
The number of oxmen or horse teams a
farmer owned determined how much labor
he was expected to provide for feudal
duties and how much he had to pay in
taxes. Small farmers with only a few
animals could use smaller tools and had
limited access to shared pastures.
Larger herds allowed participation in
slaughtering events, local markets, and
the use of communal meadows, all of
which brought higher standing in the
village community. A symbolic glimpse of
peasant status can be seen in an artwork
by Alrech Dura, showing two farmers
emphasizing their masculinity. One
places a sword before him, the other
wears a heavy knife at his belt. Even by
1600, this suggested that a member of
the rural upper class carried a sense of
dignity or gravitas.
The meer, the steward managing the farm
on behalf of the lord, held an
administrative position, usually secured
by inheritance. Jurors in the village
court were always full farmers, each
owning one or more full farms. Their
daughters could sometimes marry into the
nightly class if they were wealthy
enough. A literary example is the tale
of Hellreck, the son of a meer, who ends
up as a robber knight, a symbol that
social mobility from farming to nobility
was theoretically possible, though
rarely smooth. In contrast stood the
cottages and Katner who owned only a
tiny house or a small house plot. While
they were part of the village community,
they had no political rights or equal
access to shared lands.
Day laborers and farm hands occupied the
very bottom of the village hierarchy.
They lived on other farmers land and had
no claim to property.
Peasant clothing ranged widely in
quality. Generally, medieval clothing
was made at home. Women spun fibers from
flax or wool. Weavers created linen or
wool fabrics. And tanners prepared
leather for simple boots or shoes.
A widespread misconception suggests that
peasant clothing was poor, rough, and
shabby. In reality, weaving wool and
linen was a daily craft, and medieval
fabrics often had impressive quality.
Those who worked with fine wool could
produce garments that lasted for
decades. So, the idea that they
deliberately made lowquality clothing is
simply false.
At the same time, peasants were bound by
strict textile and clothing regulations
during the high and late middle ages.
As early as the mid12th century, church
chronicles stated that peasants should
wear gray or undyed fabrics to set them
apart from the urban and noble classes.
These dress codes were tied to local or
royal decrees. For instance, peasants
weren't allowed to use more than seven
L's, a medieval unit of length of cloth
for shirts, pants, and shoes. The
Bavarian peace of 1244 even banned
peasants from wearing luxurious colorful
fabrics or garments with silk trim.
Among the noble and urban classes, these
clothing rules were a point of pride, a
way to uphold their own moral and social
standing. But sometimes sharp criticism
flared up against peasants living above
their means who dared to buy fancy belts
or pearlstudded headpieces. In fact, the
upper peasant class had its own taste
for fashion. Satirical poems from
courtly literature poke fun at peasants
wearing shirts decorated with glittering
cords and silver buttons.
A famous image from the H Highleberg
song manuscript around 1600 shows a
peasant sporting a fine ruffled shirt,
the kind popular among the nobility. All
of this fed into a cultural anxiety
among nobles and towns people who feared
that peasants were no longer humble and
modest, but were pushing into urban
fashion trends, threatening to blur the
established social hierarchy.
Chapter 4. Gardens and agricultural
tools in the Middle Ages.
Beyond farmland and meadows, one of the
most important parts of a medieval farm
was the household garden. The old German
word gate originally meant enclosed
area. Usually a plot surrounded by
hedges or fences where vegetables and
herbs were grown. Legally, the garden
was considered a protected space, much
like the house itself, and there were
clear rules about who was allowed to
plant there. Inside these gardens,
farmers grew vegetables like cabbage and
turnips. Millet was also part of the
garden culture as it was less important
on the open fields. Typical fiber plants
such as flax for linen or matter for
dying were raised in small garden plots,
too. Legumes, peas, beans, lentils were
vital because they enriched the soil and
provided protein. Herbs like parsley,
dill, margarm, and coriander were used
to enhance flavor in cooking. For every
farming family, the household garden was
the minimum source of daily nutrition.
vegetables, herbs, often a few wild
greens like spinach or even foraged
plants such as ground elder and nettles.
All of these complimented the
grain-based diet. A farmer without a
garden, villagers said, stood at the
very bottom of the social ladder.
Without garden space, there was no way
to grow fresh produce. In the early
medieval period, most farming tools were
made entirely of wood, plows, harrows,
wooden sled carts, and simple threshing
sledges. But by the 12th century, iron
tools became increasingly common.
Sickles, knives, harotines, and
plowshares were reinforced with iron,
making them sturdier and longerlasting.
Sythes which were initially used just
for cutting wood soon developed
tooththed edges for cleaner cuts when
harvesting.
The biggest breakthrough was the move
from the light scratch plow to the heavy
moldboard plow. The old scratch plow
common in the early middle ages just
scraped the surface of the soil. To
loosen the ground properly, farmers had
to plow across the same field again in
another direction.
Later came the wheeled plow, which sat
between the scratch plow and the
moldboard plow. Its wheels made it
easier to steer the animals pulling it.
But the real gamecher was the heavy
moldboard plow. It had been around since
ancient times, but only became widely
used in Europe around the 10th century.
Its special curved moldboard turned and
broke up the soil, making it much better
for heavy clay lands and helping keep
weeds down.
At first, oxen were still the main draft
animals. Their cloven hooves, protected
by primitive hoof coverings, made them
steadier on swampy terrain. But with the
introduction of the padded horse collar,
farmers increasingly turned to horses. A
single horse could pull roughly the same
load as a pair of oxen, but was faster
and more resilient.
It wasn't until the 15th century that
the reversible mold board, allowing
furrows to be plowed evenly in both
directions, fully caught on. Before
that, farmers usually plowed in only one
direction and had to reverse the plow at
the edge of each field.
In medieval times, there was a strict
distinction between household rights,
the private sacred rights within the
family home and village rights, which
governed the farmyard, the garden, and
all shared lands. Inside the house, the
family head near absolute authority over
the household, spouse, children, and
servants alike. But as soon as you
stepped out onto the farm or garden,
depending on your social rank, village
rights came into play. Even a garden,
though technically private, fell under
the communal order. In an ideal medieval
Halandorf, a clustered village typical
of the 16th century, the church with its
fenced cemetery stood at the center. As
villages settled permanently, cemeteries
moved into the heart of the village.
People were now buried within the
village. Surrounding the church were
individual farms, each enclosed by small
gardens with woven fences. You often saw
small ramps, ladders, or stepping stones
over the fences, keeping animals out,
but letting the family easily access the
garden. The village commons included
central grassy areas, wells, communal
bakehouses, village smithies, and if
present, large grain stores. Around the
village stretched the communal farmland
divided into units called zelen.
Each zelge operated on a three field
rotation system. One/3 for summer crops
like barley or oats, one/3 for winter
crops like wheat or rye and 1/3 left as
pasture or meadow to recover. Each
farmer worked narrow strips of land in
the big shared fields laid out in long,
slim plots. This shape made it easier to
plow and sew in straight lines without
disturbing the soil too much. But to
keep everything running smoothly, the
whole village followed a strict farming
calendar. When to plow, when to plant,
when to let animals graze. This system
called field obligation was key to
making the three field rotation work.
Anyone who broke the rules could face
tough fines. In some regions, especially
in Eastern Germany, you didn't have
these clustered villages. Instead,
farmers lived in street villages where
homes lined a road, and each house had a
long, narrow strip of land stretching
out behind it. These farmers could work
their own land more freely without
having to follow the strict shared
calendar. Beyond the private fields and
homes were the communal lands, shared
pastures, meadows, orchards, woods,
streams, and ponds. Access to these
depended on status. Full farmers who
owned large farms had rights to use the
best spots because they also provided
labor and equipment when needed. Small
holders and day laborers often had
little or no access to these shared
resources.
In every village, people shared simple
tools for transport, like big wagons,
especially important during hay harvest.
These wagons carried the hay from the
fields to the barns where it was stored
for winter feed. Without them, it would
have been nearly impossible to handle
large hay harvests. Villages also ran
communal mills. windmills or water
mills, though these usually belong to
the local lord or the church.
Villagers had to bring their grain there
to be ground and pay a fee. Other shared
spaces included bake houses and wine
sellers, which were built using village
funds, but managed together. Not every
farmhouse had its own oven or wine
press, so these communal places were
essential for daily needs and
celebrations.
A drawing from the 1600s shows how
villages set up their own bakeouses and
wine sellers to provide bread and wine.
Managing all this shared infrastructure
was the job of elected local officials
like debt collectors, village judges and
jurors.
Chapter 5. Commons village organization
and social stratification in the late
middle ages. As villages settled
permanently and became self-sufficient,
they shared access to common land, the
shared spaces beyond private farms. This
included roads, pastures, meadows,
forests, streams, and ponds, as well as
temporary or seasonal operations like
lime kils, quaries, or simple iron
works. In the high middle ages, as the
need for steel and iron grew, villagers
searched for local bog iron, set up
small furnaces and produced limited
amounts of iron. But these workshops
didn't run year round. If there was no
demand, they just stopped since there
were no steady markets or trade
networks. Sometimes any extra iron was
sold in the nearest towns or markets.
Access to shared village resources was
usually limited to farmers who owned
full-sized farms. Small holders and
landless villagers often had little or
no access and had to buy things like
iron or lime from the local steward or
the monastery.
These limits led to tensions, especially
in the early 1400s and 1500s when
peasants protested what they saw as the
plundering of the commons. Nobles and
church leaders tried to take over shared
lands, turning them into private grazing
fields or expanding their hunting
grounds, which cut off peasants from
using them. Hunting bans were issued and
lands that had once been shared were
placed under the lord's control.
In response, village communities began
handling more administrative tasks that
had once been controlled by the lords.
They enforced local farming rules,
setting the calendar for planting,
harvesting, and grazing. stewards or tax
collectors gathered payments, usually a
tenth of the harvest, and delivered it
to the Lord's storehouse. Over time,
these village positions were no longer
held only by big land owners, but were
often filled by elected community
members. The village increasingly acted
as a collective representing the
interests of all its farmers.
Village courts also took on judicial
functions. These local courts made up of
a village judge, jurors, and headmen
settled disputes between farmers such as
border disagreements, conflicts over
labor obligations, or claims to the
commons. They didn't handle major
crimes, murder, robbery, or serious
breaches of peace remained under the
jurisdiction of higher courts. But for
civil matters like inheritance or
communal rights, the village court was
far more connected to daily life than
distant feudal or princely judges. At
the same time, princely and clerical
holdings maintain their own rights
within the village. preserved hunting
grounds, private meadows, fish ponds,
mills, bridges, tithe barns, parish
houses, and monastic farms. The church
received its share of the tithe
directly. A portion of the village
harvest went straight to the clergy.
Small shrines and chapels at the
village's edge reflected this
overlapping presence of village
self-ruule and ecclesiastical authority.
By the late Middle Ages, village society
had become sharply divided. At the top
were full farmers, families who owned at
least one full-sized farm. They had
voting rights in village matters, full
access to shared lands, could build up
reserves, keep herds of animals, and
handle their duties on their own terms.
Below them were the half-free peasants
who worked directly for the local lord.
While technically not free, some could
rise in status by becoming trusted
servants of the nobility.
Smallh holders who only had a tiny house
and maybe a small garden or a little bit
of farmland had no rights to the main
farmland or shared resources. They also
had no vote in village decisions. Day
laborers owned no land at all. They
survived by working for daily wages,
mostly during harvest, and often worked
on the farms of richer neighbors. At the
very bottom were servants who were
completely landless and not even counted
as part of the formal village community.
Their lives were controlled by the
households they worked for, and any
concerns they had were represented by
their masters.
Already in the 14th and 15th centuries,
as regional rulers expanded their
administrative systems, this village
state began to crumble.
Local village judges and jurors were
gradually replaced by stateappointed
stewards and tax collectors. Many
village rights shifted to the
territorial lords who installed their
own forest officials or customs posts.
Peasants protested these changes during
the peasant uprisings, especially
between 1449 and 1455,
demanding the preservation of local
communal rights and the return of the
commons they had used for generations.
Chapter 6. Social differentiation and
peasant everyday culture.
A famous image by Alrechdura from around
1600 shows two farmers posed
confidently. One has placed a sword on
the table before him while the other
wears a sturdy knife at his belt. Both
signal we are not just primitive farmers
but members of a rural upper class,
people with rights and dignity.
At the top of the village stood the
local leaders, sometimes hereditary,
sometimes elected by village assemblies.
They represented the community in
dealings with the landlord and made sure
farming rules and shared rights were
respected.
Working alongside them were stewards who
managed small farms for the lord and
local judges who handled civil or land
disputes.
Whether a farm stayed in the family over
generations depended a lot on local
laws. In areas with Frankish law, like
parts of Franconia or the Rine region,
the system of equal inheritance applied.
When a farmer died, all sons inherited
equally, dividing the land again and
again until none of the pieces were big
enough to support a family. These
shrinking plots forced many heirs to
take on extra work like day labor or
small crafts just to get by.
In contrast, regions under Saxon law
such as Saxony or Meccllinburgg followed
a system where the entire farm went to
the main heir, usually the eldest son.
The siblings got compensation or small
goods, but the farm itself stayed whole.
In many areas, this system lasted into
the 18th century.
Even among full farmers, there were
layers. Below them were half farmers,
quarter farmers, and even smaller
holders, each with just part of a full
farm, often split among several
brothers. Below that came small holders
with only a house and garden, but no
stable or large fields. Lower still were
the day laborers who owned nothing and
worked for others when needed. At the
very bottom were the servants who worked
on farms, often without pay and had no
political voice at all.
Livestock holdings were another key
marker of social status.
Farmers who owned more draft animals,
oxmen or horses, had greater
transportation capacity and were often
exempt from certain labor duties. The
number of oxmen or horses was both a
signal of wealth and a practical tool.
Someone with even a single team could
work a field independently, while those
without teams had to perform extra labor
just to get by. The village economy
extended well beyond simple farming.
Wagon makers built carts. Blacksmiths
shaped iron tools. Tanners produced
leather. Binders tied together grain
sheav. Brick makers and potters crafted
clay vessels. and weavers and spinners
supplied families with linen and wool
fabrics. These trades were usually tied
to farming families, but by the late
14th and 15th centuries, they
increasingly evolved into specialized
village groups that formed their own
guilds.
Clothing was often handmade in rural
households. Wool and linen were the most
common materials. Wool came from local
sheep, while linen was spun from flax.
The fibers were spun by hand spindles,
woven into yarn, and then dyed. Colored
fabrics were especially valued among
peasants. Normally, farmers wore gray or
natural colored linen or wool garments,
but wealthier households could afford
more colorful materials. Occasionally,
well-off peasants decorated their
clothing with pearlstudded accessories,
wore stylish leather belts with metal
ornaments, or embroidered their hats
with colorful threads. Local nobles
often complain that these farmers were
living beyond their means, wearing silk
trims or gold buttons on their shirts,
blurring the social lines that the elite
wanted to maintain.
Peasant clothing was functional above
all. Men typically wore tunics and
trousers made from tightly woven wool
fabric along with leather lace up shoes
that were sturdy but not stylish. Women
often wore long linen dresses with
simple decorative borders as well as
linen or wool caps or hairetss.
Children's clothing followed the same
patterns as the adults, though made in
smaller sizes. A farmer who had no
access to dye plants or colored threads
usually stuck to undyed linen or wool.
But wealthier farmers invested in
materials like wool dyed with wde or
matter which gave their clothing more
vibrant and intense colors.
Chapter 7. Food and eating culture among
medieval farmers.
The diet of medieval farmers was far
from boring or bland. People today often
assume peasants just lived on thin oat
porridge or plain gr. But in reality,
the variety of their meals were
surprisingly rich. Grains played a
central role in their diet. In the early
Middle Ages, millet was one of the most
common crops grown in home gardens.
Farmers cooked it into hearty porrges,
sometimes with milk, sometimes with
water, and even shaped it into small
dumplings.
In poorer regions, millet often replaced
the more expensive wheat. Barley was
another staple, sewn in the spring and
harvested by late summer. It worked well
in porridge, stews, or as feed for
animals. Oats, meanwhile, were mostly
grown to feed horses and were usually
harvested in the fall, so you rarely saw
oat fields in late spring. Rye was
especially important in cooler
mountainous regions. As a winter grain,
it was resilient and could handle damp
conditions, making it the main
ingredient for bread, especially during
tough times when food was scarce. Wheat
on the other hand was considered a
luxury. It had higher yields but was
more vulnerable to mildew in wet areas.
So only the best lands were used for it
and it was highly priced. When it came
to bread, it's worth knowing that in the
early Middle Ages, bread wasn't
something every household had daily.
Home ovens were rare, and if a family
didn't own one, they had to rely on the
village bake house. Villages often had
communal bake houses where people could
bake their bread for a fee or by
offering labor in return. Making bread
required sourdough starters that
families carefully preserved across
generations.
Many poorer families rarely baked bread
and instead relied on porridge as their
staple food. When they did eat bread, it
was often broken into pieces, not
sliced, and typically dipped into soups
or stews to soften it. Porridge, or what
they called mush, was the backbone of
the medieval peasants diet. But it
wasn't just thin, watery, grl. These
porr,
sometimes so firm they were almost
slicable, much like today's palenta.
Dumplings back then resembled heavy
bread dumplings or dense wheat porrges
shaped into balls. Many recipes blurred
the lines. A barley or rye porridge
sweetened with honey and herbs could be
a filling meal on its own. Vegetables
and field crops also played a big role.
Cabbage, both white and seavoy
varieties, was one of the main summer
and fall vegetables and could be
preserved through fermentation or
pickling, providing vital vitamins in
the winter months. Root vegetables like
carrots and yellow turnips were
initially grown more for animal feed,
but by the high middle ages had become
common on the dinner table. Legumes like
peas, beans, and lentils, known back
then as salad, were a key source of
protein and also improved soil health,
making them valuable both in the kitchen
and on the farm.
Herbs rounded out the medieval flavor
pallet. Parsley, dill, coriander,
margarm, juniper, fennel and carowway
were widely used not just to season food
but also for healing and as natural
fragrances.
Medieval records from as early as the
Carolian Empire list pages of herbs
cultivated for food, medicine, and
scent. Even dye plants like w matter and
turmeric were sometimes grown alongside
herbs, especially by peasants who
doubled as dyers, coloring fabrics for
clothing.
When it came to protein, medieval farm
households had more variety than you
might think. Pigs were the favorite
animals for home slaughter because they
could eat kitchen scraps and turn them
into valuable meat. Cows were mostly
kept for their milk, while sheep and
goats provided not just meat, but also
wool and hides for clothing and tools.
Poultry was everywhere. Chickens were
especially popular because they grew
quickly. In just about 40 days, you
could raise a chick into a slaughter
ready bird. Farmers also kept ducks,
geese, and sometimes guinea foul. Eggs
and chicken meat were key sources of
protein in the spring and summer.
Wild game added more variety. Small game
like hairs or partridges were caught
using traps, nets, or small crossbows.
Only the local elite like wealthy full
farmers or free men were allowed to hunt
with larger crossbows.
Specialized hunters such as falconers
usually worked for noble estates or
monasteries. Fish was another important
part of the diet. People ate fresh or
smoked river fish and pond fish,
including herring, halibet, and
sometimes saltwater fish brought inland.
By the late Middle Ages, some regions
had well-developed pond farming,
especially using mill ponds, which
boosted the local fish supply.
Milk products and honey were essential
household staples. Butter was a
fantastic way to preserve milk for the
winter, and it served as both a cooking
fat and a flavor booster.
Cheese came in many forms. Hard cheese,
soft cheese, or fresh cheese, depending
on the region and how long it was aged.
Cheese was not just a vital food reserve
for the cold months, but also a valuable
product for trade. Buttermilk, left over
from making butter, was either drunk or
used as fertilizer in the vegetable
garden. And then there was honey. Both
wild forest honey and honey from village
beekeepers were highly praised. Honey
was one of the best and most expensive
sweeteners and was often used as a form
of payment, a real symbol of rural
self-sufficiency.
Fruit and foraged foods rounded out the
medieval farm diet. Many farms had
orchards or shared access to community
fruit trees like apples, pears, and
cherries. Wild plants like berries,
mushrooms, and herbs were gathered from
the surrounding countryside.
People also collected wild greens like
wild garlic, ground elder, nettles, and
dandelion along with edible or medicinal
roots and berries like mugwart, borage
or juniper berries. Herbs and flavorings
came mainly from local gardens. Farmers
grew parsley, dill, coriander, margarm,
sage, savory, and thyme to season their
dishes. Vinegar made from sour wine or
cider added sharpness to meals. For
cooking fats, they used lard from pigs,
which packed both calories and taste.
Salt was one of the most precious
ingredients. It had to be mined from
salt works or imported over long trade
routes and was costly. Pepper was
considered a luxury spice, rarely seen
in peasant households, though from the
high middle ages onward, small amounts
sometimes made their way into rural
kitchens.
Preservation techniques were essential
for surviving the winter. Drying was
common. People hung meat, fish,
vegetables, and herbs in drying rooms or
laid them out on racks.
Smoking was another popular method.
Bacon, fish, meat, and cheese were cured
in the smokeouses attached to
farmhouses. Sultting and pickling were
also widespread. Fish and meat were
soaked in brine while vegetables,
fruits, and herbs were preserved in
vinegar or oil.
The rhythm of medieval farm life was
shaped by the seasons. In the summer,
fresh herbs from the garden, berries,
wild greens, and fresh caught fish
filled the table. Autumn was the peak
season for harvesting vegetables and
fruits like apples and pears, but also
for slaughtering animals, especially
pigs, and for making cider and fruit
wine.
Winter was all about surviving on stored
foods, hearty stews, thick porrges, root
vegetables, pickled goods, honey,
cheese, butter, and smoked meats.
Spring, particularly during Lent and the
fasting period, often meant facing the
leanest weeks when there was little
fresh food. Instead of meat, people
relied on fish like carp and proteinrich
legumes such as beans and peas.
Chapter 8. Leisure, folk culture, and
the yearly work cycle.
In the daily life of a medieval farmer,
the idea of free time as we know it
barely existed. Almost every moment was
tied to work on the house, the farm, or
within the village. But that didn't mean
people never had fun. Quite the
opposite, there were many ways for
villagers to relax, celebrate, and enjoy
culture together. Village taverns began
popping up as early as the High Middle
Ages. These inns were easy to spot. They
often had wooden signs with symbols or
crests hanging over their doors. The
windows were small, sometimes fitted
with lattice patterns to help keep the
warmth inside. At the entrance, you
might find small pass through doors
designed so the inkeeper could hand out
food and drinks without having to walk
all the way across the tavern room. In
spring, villagers built simple outdoor
stages to host plays. Local actors
performed biblical stories or legends,
and the sword dance was a highlight. Men
in leather trousers, waving swords and
bright cloths, danced in formation, not
to show fighting skill, but to display
social rank since only free farmers
could own swords.
Shooting clubs were common, too. In the
evenings, farmers practiced with bows or
crossbows, aiming at targets near the
village windmill.
These practices evolved into lively
shooting festivals where one person was
crowned the village marksman.
Big festivals like weddings, church
feasts, or village fairs brought
everyone together. Squares were
decorated with flags. Villagers danced,
played games, or competed in long jumps
and stonethrowing contests. Religious
events like processions or local
pilgrimages also played a big role,
blending spiritual life with community
bonding. Groups walked to small chapels,
stopping to pray, sing, and rest, making
these moments both devotional and
social. And after long work days,
villagers gathered to play dice or early
card games like tarot. Not just to
gamble, but to relax and enjoy time
together.
Now, let's walk through the typical
farming year as it was shown in medieval
illustrated calendars and books of ours.
Month by month, the rhythm of farm life.
In January, farmers focused on indoor
chores. Women spun flax, men wo linen,
and families did small repairs around
the house. They also chopped firewood
for the winter and cleaned out the
animal stalls, making sure the cattle
and pigs were wellfed and warm. Some
even transported firewood to city
markets to sell.
February brought more of the same.
indoor work like repairs and
woodworking, crafting tools and
maintaining the household. Beekeepers
checked their hives and collected wax
for making candles or other goods. More
wood was brought into town for trade or
sale.
March marked the start of outdoor
repairs. Farmers mended fences and
pasture enclosures, pulled weeds, and
worked the soil. Plowing began in
earnest. oxen or horses were harnessed
to simple plows, readying the fields for
spring crops like oats.
By April, attention shifted to garden
work. Families turned over the garden
beds, spread manure, and planted beans
and peas. Field work picked up, too,
with plowing and harrowing for the
summer grains. The animals were driven
out onto the pastures, marking the true
start of the outdoor farming season.
In May, there was less pressure from
heavy farm work, and people finally had
time for themselves. Villagers gathered
by the riverside to dance, took
refreshing swims in local ponds, or set
out on small boat rides, even chilling
drinks by lowering metal flasks into the
cool current. May, often called the
month of joy, was mostly given over to
celebrating springtime with fewer
demands from the fields. By June,
though, the real work picked up again.
Farmers headed out to cut hay, swinging
their sides through the tall grasses,
carefully laying the cutings on linen
sheets before loading them onto big
wooden wagons. Back at the barns, they
heaved the hay up into the lofts,
packing it tightly to build the winter
supply of animal fodder. Without this
hard work, there would be no way to keep
the livestock fed during the cold
months.
July brought the grain harvest. Oats and
barley were ready to cut, and farmers
bent over the fields with sickles,
working carefully to gather as much as
possible. In some places, they used
special tooththed sickles to speed up
the cutting. At the same time, berries,
early apples, and cherries were being
picked, adding fresh fruit to the
household stores. Once the grain was
cut, it was brought to the village
threshing floors, broad packed earth
spaces, or even public squares where it
was tossed into the air, letting the
wind help separate the chaff from the
kernels. Sometimes they dragged rough
wooden boards covered with flint across
the grain to break it apart more
efficiently.
Once cleaned, the precious grain was
moved into tall storage barns, stacked
carefully away for the months ahead.
As August rolled in, the harvest season
wrapped up. Farmers dried the last of
the sheav under the open sky, finished
threshing, and then turned to clearing
the fields. Leftover straw was chopped
down, and the land was made ready for
the sewing of winter crops.
September brought the grape harvest in
wine growing regions like Franconia, the
Mosul Valley, and the Rine. Wine farmers
often enjoyed a higher status since
wine-making was seen as a prestigious
and skilled craft. Meanwhile, in other
parts of the countryside, farmers were
already sewing rye and wheat for the
winter season. It was also the start of
the acorn feeding season when pigs were
driven into the forests to fatten up on
fallen acorns and beach nuts, helping to
build up their meat before the winter
slaughter. In the wine regions, fresh
grapes were stored in cool underground
cellers where they would slowly ferment
into wine. October was a time to finish
planting rye and wheat and to begin
slaughtering cattle. Beef was especially
prized for feasts or winter storage, and
farmers also focused on drying fruits
like apples and pears and gathering
herbs for the long cold season ahead.
In November, pigs were still being
fattened in the woods, getting them
ready for slaughter. Farmers also worked
on processing flax, breaking the tough
stalks to extract fibers for linen
making. With winter closing in, they
repaired tools, treated leather, and
made sure they had everything ready for
the next spring's planting.
December brought the big pig slaughter,
a major event that filled winter stores
with bacon, sausages, and ham. This
usually happened before Christmas when
the cold helped preserve the meat.
Families also baked big batches of bread
and spent the dark days weaving, mending
clothes, and repairing shoes.
These monthly rhythms appear in many
medieval manuscripts and calendars like
the book of hours of the Duke Deer, the
Celestat Psalms or the H Highleberg song
manuscript.
Even back in the Carolinian period
around 8:18, foldable calendars like the
Capitular Devilis showed peasants at
work capturing the farm cycle across the
12 months. Life in the medieval world
was deeply tied to this steady seasonal
rhythm.
Chapter nine. Village-based
entertainment and festival culture.
In the villages, there were all kinds of
community entertainment. The idea that
rural life was only about hard, boring
farm labor is simply wrong and just as
false as the picture of a helpless,
suffering peasant. Village taverns were
often built at the far edge of the
village near main roads or watermills. A
tavern usually had a sign hanging
outside, maybe a wooden cup, a knife, or
a rooster, and its windows were fitted
with lattises, protecting the guests
inside while still allowing them to look
out. Special little doors let the
inkeeper pass food and drinks to hungry
farm workers without them needing to
come inside the main room.
In early spring, villagers would set up
makeshift wooden stages in the center of
town for carnival plays. Local teenagers
often took part performing comedies,
ballads, or religious mystery plays. One
special tradition was the sword dance
where farmers dressed in costumes and
sashes carrying swords moved in
choreographed steps on the stage.
These dances weren't just for
entertainment. They were a way for the
village to show itself as a proud
independent community. Near some
windmills or watermills, you could find
target boards where villagers practiced
shooting with crossbows, long bows, or
even slingshots.
Over time, these shooting groups became
formal guilds. Being chosen as the
vill's shooting king was a big honor,
and neighbors from other villages were
often invited for competitions. The
mills were a practical location. They
made enough noise to cover the sounds of
practice and stood as clear landmarks.
Dice and card games made their way north
from southern Europe. By the 1300s,
peasants were already gathering in
taverns or at festivals to play dice
games. Card games like Tarokino or
Lorenzo Ilmaniko
were more common among the wealthy or
nobility. But by the 1400s, simpler
cards began to spread into the
countryside.
Villagers also organized competitions.
Long jumping, stone throwing, or
wrestling matches were held in the
village squares. These weren't really
about fame or prizes. They were about
shared experience, fun, and testing each
other's strength. Games with balls or
bowlinglike contests were popular at
harvest festivals or church fairs.
People would roll balls toward targets
set in grooves or ditches, similar to
early versions of bowling.
Village festivals, like harvest fairs or
church feast days, were colorful and
lively. Flags and banners, much like
city guild flags, marked which village
group or association was organizing the
event. For example, during a
Thanksgiving procession, the village
leader might carry the Sebastian banner,
a red penant with an image of St.
Sebastian.
During these festivals, villagers
gathered in taverns or big barns to
dance, eat, laugh, and sometimes argue
loudly. A 16th century illustration
shows long wooden benches and tables,
people drinking from clay mugs or brass
cups, and beer drawn from large barrels.
Outside, families would sit on benches
sipping local wine, beer, or mead.
In some villages, there were public
bathous with wooden tubs or shared bath
areas, especially in forested regions
where firewood was easy to find. Where
wood was scarce, wealthier folks would
just head to the local mill pond for a
cooling dip. One old illustration even
shows farmers splashing in a mill pond
right beside the rushing water of the
mill race. Athletic events were another
favorite pastime. Farmers organized
races down long field paths to test
their stamina, or they'd gather on open
land to see who could throw a heavy
stone the farthest. Archery was both a
hobby and a serious skill. Practicing
with long bows was essential, whether
for hunting or for village contests.
Religion played a huge role in village
life, and processions were a regular
part of the year. On feast days,
villagers would walk through the
village, passing wayside shrines,
chapels, and the rectory.
Many villages had small pilgrimage sites
with merry chapels or statues of saints,
and these became yearly pilgrimage
destinations. Even though these trips
took time, they were an important mix of
spiritual devotion and social bonding. A
famous painting by Peter Bugal the Elder
around 1568
shows a village festival packed with
people. You can see villagers drinking
wine, dancing, performing sword dances,
or shooting crossbows all in one lively
scene. A night fights a dragon-shaped
wagon while the local shooting club
practices by the windmill in the
background. Drums, bag pipes, and
trumpets filled the air, reminding us
that fun and folklore were not limited
to city life.
Sometimes villages even competed with
their neighbors to see who could throw
the most impressive festival. Behind the
big banner, you'd spot the village
tavern with its carved bottle sign on
the gable, marking the connection to
local wine sellers. The lattis windows
showed that both display and security
mattered. Carnival plays were staged on
wooden platforms in the village square,
draped in colorful cloth. You'd see
actors dressed as penitants, poking fun
at the clergy or farmers wearing
oversized headbands, humorously mimming
heavy tasks. These shows weren't just
religious. They were also a way for
villagers to express their own identity
and humor.
Sword dances stood as a status symbol.
Carrying a sword in the village signaled
that you were free, not bound to
servitude. And these dances where a
farmer stroed through the village to the
beat of drums and flutes were part of
the village's ritual memory. Even if
actual peasant warfare had mostly faded
by the late middle ages, the symbolism
remained strong. Shooting guilds
required years of practice. While city
guilds had their own shooting halls by
the 14th century, village marksmen
trained outdoors, often near the mill.
The mill's noise covered the sound of
arrows or crossbow bolts, and the tall
structure made it easy to fix target
boards where everyone could see. These
traditions reveal a lively, self-aware
village culture, one where
entertainment, ritual, and social ties
all blended together into a distinct
rural life.
Even in the long, dark months of winter,
villagers found ways to come together
and celebrate. One of the oldest and
most symbolic traditions was the sword
dance. Well into the 16th century,
farmers who owned their own swords would
gather in the village square, especially
on All Saints Day, St. Martin's Day, or
right before carnival. These dances
weren't just performances. They were a
proud display of rural dignity, a sign
that these villagers were free men, not
bound surfs.
Another key gathering spot was the
village windmill. This was where the
local shooting societies would meet.
Every Friday, farmers gathered with
their crossbows, long bows, or even
early firearms to practice shooting at
targets hung beside the mill. An old
illustration from the time shows a
village shooter carefully aiming at a
target nailed to the mill's wall, the
windmill blades turning lazily in the
background.
These sessions weren't just about skill.
They helped tie the community together,
especially when they led up to the
village shooting festivals.
Those festivals lasted from sunrise to
dusk. The best marksmen were crowned
with laurel wreaths honored with small
handcrafted musketss or beautifully
carved arrows as trophies. There was
dancing, wine, keg tossing, and plenty
of local treats like fried bread spread
thick with lard.
In some regions, villages even formed
what were known as tavern guilds. These
groups held certain rights over local
stalls, wells, or pastures. A banner
with the town's emblem would hang
proudly outside, showing that the
community was self-organized and
responsible for its members, much like
the guilds in the cities. And of course,
no village carnival was complete without
masks and disguises. During carnival,
farmers would hide behind simple linen
masks or wear wooden ones that
exaggerated the features of nobles or
clergy in comical mocking ways.
These handcarved masks, often decorated
with painted strips of fabric, were
central to traditions like the carnival
races or the ritual dragging of straw
figures across the village square.
Chapter 10. The peasant yearly rhythm.
At the end of the farming year, medieval
villagers had a very clear sense of how
life on the land and in the village had
played out for centuries.
The medieval calendars and illustrated
manuscripts captured this rhythm
beautifully month by month, showing a
world shaped by seasonal tasks and
rituals. In January and February, people
focused on indoor tasks. Weaving cloth,
making repairs, chopping firewood,
caring for the animals, and trading
timber. March and April brought the
first outdoor work of the year. Fixing
fences, pulling weeds, plowing the
fields for summer crops, reworking
garden beds, sewing seeds, and pushing
animals back out to the pastures.
May was a lighter period with little
fieldwork. Instead, people enjoyed
dancing, bathing, boating on rivers, and
the first outdoor games of spring. June
was the time for the hay harvest.
Farmers swung their sides across the
lush meadows, stacking the cutg grass
onto wagons, hauling it to the barns and
tossing it up to the high lofts where it
would stay dry as winter feed for the
animals. In July and August, the grain
harvest took center stage. Summer crops
like oats and barley were cut with
sickles, threshed, winnowed, sorted, and
carefully stored. It was also the season
for gathering fruit, cherries, plums,
berries, and drying it for winter.
September meant grape harvests in the
wine regions, careful sewing of winter
wheat and rye, and driving pigs into the
oak and beach forests to fatten on
acorns and nuts.
October and November were busy with more
sewing, cattle slaughtering, preserving
food stores, and processing flax into
linen. December was marked by the major
winter event, pig slaughtering. Families
came together to butcher salt, smoke,
and dry meat into sausages, bacon, and
hams that would last the cold months.
Villagers gathered at the communal oven
for bread baking days. While at home,
women and children worked at weaving,
sewing, patching clothes, and spinning
wool.
This tightly ordered seasonal rhythm
shows how medieval life was deeply
shaped by the cycles of farming,
livestock care, and village cooperation.
From the outside, nobles and clergy saw
peasants as the lowest social rank. But
in truth, there was no such thing as a
simple peasant. Within rural life
existed clear social layers, fulling
farmers, halfholders, cottages, day
laborers, servants, and maids, all with
distinct roles, rights, and status.
Across all the chapters of this rural
world, it becomes clear that the Middle
Ages were not an era of dull simplicity.
Farmers practiced complex crafts, worked
in cooperatives, maintained
sophisticated legal and community
systems, nurtured a rich cultural life,
and sustained a diverse food economy.
Even in times of severe hardship during
famines, pestilence, or environmental
disasters, they showed remarkable
adaptability and resilience.
Agriculture dominated medieval Europe
with around 90% of the population
working the land. Farm production
supported the building of cathedrals,
monasteries, schools, and noble estates,
while technical innovations in the high
middle ages from the heavy plow to the
three field system dramatically
increased yields. Rural settlement
shifted from scattered farms to
permanent villages shaped by the
memorial system where peasants worked
under the Lord's authority but still
held important communal rights.
Over the centuries, farmers faced cycles
of growth and crisis. The agricultural
boom of the high middle ages gave way to
the crises of the 14th century. soil
exhaustion, flooding, famine, and the
Black Death, which decimated populations
and forced a reshuffleling of labor and
landholding systems.
Yet through it all, rural families
remained the backbone of European life.
They raised vegetables, kept animals,
crafted their own tools and clothing,
prepared varied meals, celebrated
festivals, and preserved songs, rituals,
and stories.
Far from passive or primitive, these
communities demonstrated a deep and
lasting ability to organize, innovate,
and survive. living every year by the
seasons, the soil, and the strength of
the village around them.